ich bin in einem Iglu aufgewacht
Michelin hat mich nach Lappland
eingeladen ja das Michelin dass die
Sterne für gutes Essen verleiht und ja
dass das die Autoreifen macht das ist
nämlich die gleiche Firma ein steht fest
wir haben gut gegessen auf dieser Reise
ein schwedischer sternekocht der alles
über offener Flamme zubereitet hat
Austern für uns gemacht indem er
Rinderfett in einem glühenden Trichter
zum Schmelzen gebracht und darauf
geteufelt hat unglaublicher Geschmack
dann sind wir reingegangen weil es
draußen -20° waren haben Jakobsmuscheln
gegessen und sogar Rentier Fleisch das
ist nämlich eine der häufigsten
Proteinquellen Finnland würdet ihr das
Essen